The joe rogan experience is another
lesson I learned that I have to remember
four,
I forget,
um,
that I learned about the movie business.
Dave had a fucking great
movie called the wrong guy.
Yeah.
And it was a great movie
and we went to see it.
I think Brian Keaulana went to say it
with me and we were fucking howling.
And I was like,
Holy Shit,
David's going to be a huge movie star.
There's going to be a huge movie.
And I remember watching it going like,
this is like one of the best
comedies I've seen in years.
And then nothing.
Yeah.
Disney shelved it.
Well what happened was how Hollywood
pictures was our distributor Disney.
Then they shut Hollywood pictures
down in the middle of production.
And then when we were done,
they reopened Hollywood pictures,
but with the new president of Hollywood
pictures and he didn't want to touch any
of this stuff so that the other guy
had started and always are like that.
Because if it's there,
if it's a failure,
it's their failure.
Yeah.
But if it's a success,
it's the other guy success.
So they just don't deal with it.
So they uh,
so got shelved for like five years.
Like they would even admit they had it,
so it never had a theatrical release.
Never got theatrical release.
So it's available on DVD,
right.
Can't get it on amazon.com
on Amazon right now.
Really?
Well then the people just
probably pick that up.
Yeah,
I'm going to pick it up right now with
some one click while we're doing the
podcast.
It's actually what I'm,
one of the things I'm proudest of is that
movie like creatively and comedically.
It was brilliant.
You know it air it goes,
watch this one click.
Oh Don,
it's that easy.
People.
I love amazon.com.
Yeah,
that was a brilliant fucking movie.
It was really fun.
I enjoy the shit out of it and I know,
I remember you guys all
coming out to see it though,
that screening and yeah.
Yeah.
And I remember thinking after is over
after the whole thing where it didn't work
out and it never got,
I'm like,
wow,
well this is uh,
this business is crazy.
Like this place just
doesn't make any sense.
I know because we really thought we,
you know,
we were clear cause we had,
the big thing was always,
well if you're doing an independent film,
can you get distribution?
And we went into it with distribution.
We had Disney lined up
in the script phase,
you know,
uh,
so we had distribution
line that we had produced,
even had,
uh,
we were even in profit in foreign sales.
Wow.
While we were shooting the
movie based on a trailer.
Whoa.
That was taken to can,
so,
uh,
we had,
we had advanced sales,
foreign sales that put the movie
in profit while we were shooting,
but they were all
contingent on a US release.
It seems like you could get a meeting
and talk to the new head guy and go,
oh we do.
Oh,
we tried it for years.
Oh thank you.
We'll make a big deal.
We'll do press releases.
Yes.
And Oh yeah.
We tried talking to Disney for years and
they just wouldn't have anything to do
with it now.
Wow.
Other,
there were other people even tried to
buy it from Disney and they wouldn't sell
it.
Really?
Yeah.
Wow.
Because of the emphasis success,
then they fucked up.
Yeah.
Wow.
What a creepy fucking business.
You wonder why Dave
Chappelle went to Africa.
Yeah.
Well,
and it's beautiful.